et on commence lilian malet par un
dossier gênant pour le front national
qui concerne aussi la bourgogne
oui on a appris hier que le président du
parlement européen martin schulz a
diligenté une enquête au sujet d'une
vingtaine d'assistant parlementaire du
front national qui seraient payés sur
des fonds destinés aux assistants des
députés européens mais qui fred en
réalité tout autre chose pour le front
national
le parlement européen a aussi alerté la
justice française d'ailleurs et d'après
le canard enchaîné le candidat fn de
pont-sur-yonne julien odoul ferait
partie de cette liste c'est les jeunes
udi de l'yonne qui le signale sur
twitter et pour cause du lien au double
est un ancien de l'udf
contacté cet après midi julien houle ne
nous a pas répondu
et comme tous les soirs on fait un gros
plan sur un canton ce soir autant un oui
ce canton est issu de l'union de trois
cantons autun nord lucenay l'évêque et
epinac un nouveau canton mais une
tradition qui perdure la division de la
gauche véritable spécialité locale qui
se pratique aux municipales sur autun
depuis très longtemps et qui va se
prolonger dans ces élections
départementales ou deux binômes issus du
ps vont s'affronter face à une droite
unie stéphane robert et gabrielle talon
comme souvent dans l'autunois la
division n'est jamais bien loin
et une fois de plus la gauche n'a pas
réussi à s'entendre
le binôme investie par le parti
socialiste le voici
emmenés par ghislaine colombo candidate
sortante du canton autun nord
la suppléante du député philippe baumel
estime sa candidature légitime n'a pas
pu trouver d'accord et il n'y avait
aucune raison qu avec le soutien du ps
et de la majorité par te mental je
laisse la place
son colistier dominique basdevant est
issu d'une vieille famille du morvan
l'ancien élu dano s'est lancé dans cette
élection pour continuer de valoriser les
territoires ruraux
revitalise quand ans à revitaliser nos
nos campagnes nos zones rurales ici pour
amener plus d'agriculteurs plus de gens
plus de jeunes qui s'installent comme
celui là qu'est à berne où la quiète
pompiers anneaux qui travaillait au
teint et leur trouver du travail et qui
vient de s'installer ici et vivre ici de
manière à ce que nous nous comme une
vive ce nouveau canton redessiner entre
ville et campagne comprend désormais
vingt mille habitants
il s'étend des limites de la nièvre aux
frontières de la côte d'or
sans oublier une partie d'autun et face
aux électeurs il y aura donc un deuxième
binôme de gauche emmenée par jean
baptiste pierre le conseiller général
sortant de lucenay l'évêque assume cette
dissidence une division de toute façon
dans le cadre d'une élection peut poser
peut poser des problèmes
nous nous connaissons avec avec monique
gatier
depuis sept ans on travaille ensemble
depuis cette année ça a été ça a été le
choix de de partir ensemble pour des
questions liées à la fois nos profils et
à nos projets fort d'un précédent mandat
tourné vers la ruralité
le maire de sommant compte s'appuyer sur
l'expérience de monique gatier première
adjointe au maire d'autun rémy
rebeyrotte
moi j'ai un profil plus en
professionnels et d'élus sur les
affaires sociales les affaires
familiales les seniors les handicapés et
jean baptiste a peut-être un profil plus
haut débit enfin territoire plus
technique on va dire donc je pense qu'on
sera très complémentaire et qu'on pourra
se partager le travail sans difficulté
frédéric brochot candidat ump malheureux
en 2011 face à ghislaine colombo s'est
lui lancer dans cette élection avec une
élue d'épinac la ville a basculé à
droite aux dernières municipales
une droite qui se veut très
complémentaires c'est une chance
d'apporter des compétences nouvelles
une sensibilité nouvelle c'est vrai que
les femmes sont compétentes en matière
de social de l'environnement donc je à
la finesse de certain d'aborder de
certaines façons certains dossiers et
c'est vrai que avec fred on va être je
pense très complémentaires et et à tous
les niveaux à une droite très
complémentaires mais une droite réunis
avec le centre l'ump espère profiter
d'une possible dispersion des voix du
camp adverse
prudent le duo a lancé une campagne
pédagogique face à tant de changements
les personnes sont perdus pour l'instant
savent pas à quel quel canton et les
appartiennent ne savent pas quelles
personnes vont les représenter
il ya un gros travail de pédagogie c'est
pour l'instant le travail que l'on mail
le front national longtemps silencieuse
sur le sujet n'a finalement pas investi
deux candidats sur ce territoire à forte
dominante rurale
bon c'est classique en période
préélectorale ça fait partie du jeu
parfois le ton monte
oui deux belles polémiques de campagne
d'abord en côte d'or où les candidats
ump udi du canton de dijon 3 c'est un
navet ironie de l'annonce par la ville
de l'arrivée d'une nouvelle enseigne
pour une supérette dans le quartier des
grésillés qu'il qualifie de miraculeuse
pendant qu'en face le groupe de gauche
au conseil général de côte-d'or fait
remarquer que la dernière subvention
votée par la commission permanente est
destiné à une association de commerçants
dont le président est le mari de la
candidate de droite de dijon 3 justement
autre polémique en saône-et-loire qu'on
peut suivre sur le réseau facebook avec
une interview musclée chez nos confrères
du jsl du député ps christophe sirugue
qui parle je cite d'une droite
revancharde et hargneuse réponse tout
aussi musclé de l'ump 71 qui parle à son
tour d'incurie socialiste et de
puissants font de l'argent public
la tension monte en saône-et-loire
décidément la campagne s'est aussi sur
twitter parce qu'elle met avec deux
instantanée de campagne le socialiste
fabien bazin dans la nièvre qui résument
ces journées
cole affiche foire réunion il a l'air
d'y prendre du plaisir et puis autour
d'autun justement l'ump frédéric brochot
très fier de sa permanence mobile alors
c'est un autre nom pour une camionnette
bien pratique pour sillonner le morvan
et les 28 communes de son canton
c'est fini pour ce soir et demain après
la division de la gauche à autun nous
irons à joigny examiner la division de
la droite l'approché journal de campagne
ici demain merci